[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our good buddy ross tucker host of the
ross tucker football podcast works for
cbs westwood one
and uh he hosts the even money podcast
that uh you should follow on social
media at ross tucker nfl
he uh is busy calling mack action uh had
a game on tuesday night i think that was
ball state in akron he's got clemson at
louisville coming up saturday for
westwood one he's a busy man the
peripatetic ross tucker ross how are you
today
fantastic always what's up dan thursday
night football
mike white versus the colts
if he plays extremely well
do the jets then have a is it a good
thing or a bad thing if mike white plays
really well tonight against the colts
i think it's a fair question uh
ultimately it's a good thing
i think in the short term it might be
a little bit of an issue for the jets
they have to sort through but at a
minimum you don't want to rush zach
wilson back from this injury so you want
mike white to win you want mike white to
play well they're trying to build
something there a new culture with
robert sala and the jet so absolutely
they want mike white to play well i know
some jets fans kind of have mixed
emotions like wait a minute why does he
look better than zach wilson does we'll
see if that happens tonight you know
it's funny dan i was talking
with greg cosell this morning on the
ross tucker podcast he just mentioned
the bengals
were really conservative and vanilla
against mike white last sunday i mean
they really just played zone and
i think the colts will be
much more aggressive tonight i'm not
sure mike white will play that well but
if he does i know this i'll personally
be thrilled for him any of these guys
dan cooper rush mike white these guys
get a chance to actually start a game
they've been just battling scratching
clawing to stay in the league for years
i always root for these guys is it a
better story if jordan love plays well
or doesn't play well against kansas city
oh i think it's a better well
i guess it depends on your perspective
i think it's a more interesting story
how about if you're a packer fan is it
is it better that he plays well
no guarantee he wins but he plays well
or he doesn't play well
oh okay that's totally different packers
fan you absolutely want jordan love to
play well number one you want to give
your team a chance to win the game but
number two you want to feel pretty good
about what you have in love when rogers
isn't there anymore which is very likely
next year so you absolutely hope jordan
love plays well now for us
it would be interesting if jordan love
really played poorly that would make the
offseason even more interesting and
frankly it would make the entire
conversation surrounding aaron rodgers
and you know testing positive and not
being backstage it would make that even
more interesting if love it plays really
poorly
what do you think happens with the
packers
are they complicit in what happened with
aaron rodgers and what happens to aaron
rodgers you know bigger picture with not
just being uh out with covid but is he
fine is he suspended
i think there's gonna have to be some
sort of discipline now i'll say this i
don't i don't follow the rules that
closely of when they have to wear a mask
or what they have to do
if they're unvaccinated but at a minimum
it feels like
aaron rodgers and the packers
organization
were misleading in this instance so i'll
be curious to see how the nfl comes down
they know it's a very sensitive topic
and frankly
other teams are watching the thing i
keep coming back to though dan is you
know i hear all the time
whether or not your vaccinate's a
personal decision personal decision i
get that
but not really when you play for a team
right like not really for a couple
different reasons i mean number one
you know we've all read that you're less
likely to test positive less likely to
transmit it all those things if you're
vaccinated so if you're not vaccinated
you're really not quite doing what's
best for the team and then even just
forget that part of it just the nfl
nflpa rules i mean saquon barkley tested
positive but because he's vaccinated if
he gets back-to-back negative tests he
can play in the next game whereas rogers
is out at least 10 days might put him
out for the next game you know if you're
if you're a leader
and you're part of a team
it's not really the personal decision
that people talk about all the time it's
it's kind of a team decision especially
if you're a leader
and winning the super bowl going to it
winning it is supposed to be a high
priority for you i was uh
not accused of being naive but it was
mentioned i might be naive because in my
mind i'm thinking rogers in his mind
thinks that he was protected that he had
you know this holistic approach and
raise your antibodies and you're going
to be because he said when he was asked
hey have you been vaccinated and he goes
yeah i've been immunized well nobody in
the room
thought to ask him
okay was he is he playing games with
words here that maybe in his mind he
thought he was protected
although i was told maybe you're being
naive and giving rogers too much credit
that he did know what he was doing
didn't believe in getting vaccinated and
was sort of taking chances here of uh
being a spreader or getting in it
himself
well it sounds like he's got this
personal doctor that he really believes
in
and if they did some type of therapy
to try to boost his antibodies i think
on some level rogers probably did think
he was protected but to me dan
that's not the point like aaron is a
really smart guy
and the rules were very clear from the
nfl and the nflpa so listen you you
don't have to agree with the rules and i
know a lot of people don't but these are
the rules of engagement for the 2021
season so
if it's really important to you
to win as many games as possible to try
to win a super bowl all those things
you really should be vaccinated right
like if that's a high priority or
priority one
win games win the super bowl
because of the way the rules are laid
out this year you really should be
vaccinated if that's a high priority for
you yeah but he doesn't have to be
vaccinated you have carson wentz who
said i'm not vaccinated uh alan lazard
kirk cousins they've come out and said
they're not vaccinated well they're
still playing
i don't know why rogers didn't just say
look i'm not vaccinated i've been
immunized and i'll go through the covet
protocol
then i don't know if anybody would have
a problem with this because when's the
last time kirk cousins or carson wentz's
name came up that they're not vaccinated
i said at the beginning of the year
you're going to have a situation where
you have a big time quarterback test
positive and we're going to see what the
fallout is in that quarterback room well
jordan loves somehow escape this and the
third string quarterback has covered
devonte adams coming off covet allen
lizard with covet i don't know if aaron
rodgers is responsible for that but i'm
curious if you're a teammate of aaron
rodgers and you know he did this was he
being deceitful
was he was he trying to
you know
be vague
and look at what the fallout is here and
why did the packers know as well because
did they just say hey
whatever we do let's don't upset aaron
given what happened in the offseason
yeah i mean listen he didn't want all
the criticism that goes along with not
being vaccinated okay he knows it's a
polarizing topic and he didn't want to
face the wrath of the media it's that
simple because otherwise he would have
totally owned it and i actually give
credit to kirk cousins and carson wentz
for owning it here's the thing though
dan i really believe that if cousins and
wence tested positive and missed games
in the regular season i think we would
be up in arms anyway they both tested
positive in the preseason so they they
already missed their time during
preseason i said back then if this
happens to a guy that's especially
unvaccinated during the season it's
going to be a really big deal and it is
if cousins or wins test the positive now
and had to miss 10 days maybe two games
i think they'd be getting a lot of flack
as well maybe not as much as rogers
because people didn't know that rogers
one was unvaccinated but they'd still be
getting a lot of criticism he's ross
tucker former nfl lineman he works for
cbs westwood one and host of the ross
tucker football podcast you can follow
him at ross tucker nfl the odell beckham
jr situation
does he have a point
about baker mayfield
well
he can be frustrated that he doesn't get
the ball more but dan i played for five
teams i never once met a wide receiver
that didn't think they should get the
ball more
and this video his dad puts out there
you know anybody could do a video look
you know what dan you know i'm gonna put
a video out there five minutes of my nfl
career and everybody will think i was
really really good guess what i wasn't
you can do anything with videos maybe
maybe about three minutes
but but the point is is
okay so his dad posts a video of when
he's open and doesn't get the ball
every receiver's dad can do that and by
the way what are you doing
having your dad do that
and don't tell me odell wasn't in on it
because it's not a coincidence that the
same day lebron james tweets free obj
okay like this is an orchestrated
coordinated thing frankly
honestly this is really bad i mean i'm
embarrassed for him like i'm embarrassed
that he had his dad do that i mean what
what's next dan next time i'm filling in
for you am i going to have my mom call
you and ask if i can get a little bit
more money when i feel like what are we
like you're a grown man you're an adult
and honestly it's cowardly like i have a
lot more respect for guys that say
you know i i i wish i was getting the
ball more i'm not happy you have your
buddy lebron tweet something and your
dad post a video it's passive aggressive
pathetic do you think though
he has a point that baker mayfield is
just not a good enough quarterback
i don't think that's his point i think
it is i think he's saying i'm open he
can't make these throws he doesn't he
doesn't pull the trigger quick enough
and if you look at now granted it's 11
minutes that's been edited together to
make odell look good and baker to look
bad but there are moments that fill up
11 minutes even though some are in slow
motion that baker mayfield does miss
throws with odell beckham
yeah but they all do
i mean i i think there's two different
things if he just doesn't like doesn't
think baker mayfield's good enough okay
i think he thinks that baker doesn't
look for him i think he thinks that that
baker doesn't want to throw him the ball
back
okay but look baker needs odell beckham
to get a new contract
right i don't agree
i actually think if you look at over the
last couple years they're better without
them well i don't want
i don't want odell beckham on my team
but he is extremely talented and i do
think that you need to put up some
passing numbers you know they're a
running team
and there's a reason why because they're
more confident in running the football
than they are passing it even with
jarvis landry and odell beckham most
teams would be a past team first i'd i
think there's still questions with baker
mayfield here i don't like the way
o'dell did this but i think odell did it
because he knew hey go ahead cut me and
pay me and i'll go find another team
well there's definitely questions with
baker mayfield especially as it relates
to whether or not he gets a big time
long-term contract but as it relates to
odell beckham jr i don't really know how
talented he really is anymore
and baker mayfield and the browns have
clearly played better without him throw
the ball to landry throw the ball at
diamond people's jones they've got three
good tight ends their backs are
excellent out of the backfield they
don't need odell beckham jr but he was
smart the way he timed it yeah because
no one's gonna pick him up on waivers
now because of his salary so
if they cut him
he'll be able to sign with whatever team
he wants i mean they're they're trying
to figure out the money right now they
want to get rid of him if he if he
wasn't guaranteed all this money he
would have been cut already yeah i think
that he's you know they held him out of
practice again today and i think
according to the cba mike florio said
you're not allowed to do that you can't
hold him out uh he has to be able to
come back if he wants to come back so
you have to either allow him to come
back or you release him
and i think that's what he's hoping for
and
who knows where he ends up but it feels
like he's going to get paid and then get
paid again
and
going to get his get out of jail card
who really wants him
i mean
what he's doing right now the saints
would take him right now yeah you know
what that's fair and i think they
probably would i don't think you get a
lot of money but
he's injured a lot
he's not productive
he doesn't get along with quarterbacks
like eli manning and baker mayfield and
this is the second time in a row
that he's kind of tried to force his way
out
who's looking for that i mean that's the
grand slam right there of four things i
don't want on my team yeah but antonio
brown
he got a couple of second chances third
chances
much better player i think than odell
was at this time i agree
but you're right
he'll go he'll go to the saints or
somewhere and
i guess he'll get the ball more and i i
don't know i mean i i don't think he's
very good anymore uh but i think he
realizes that people are feeling that
way and he wants to go somewhere else to
prove that he's still got it great to
talk to you ross as always thank you
buddy safe travels
absolutely thank you see ya that's ross
tucker host of the ross tucker football
podcast one of our favorites works for
cbs westwood one